[Music]
so when I think about you first of all
welcome thank you for doing this today
thanks for coming out here when I think
about you I think about somebody who
spent a lot of time basically thinking
about thinking somebody who is trying to
divine the difference between knowledge
and understanding and to kind of coin a
phrase used widely by you've all know a
Harare
perfecting or optimizing this idea that
that clarity is power I totally agree
with that thanks for having me yeah
where to begin I mean I think that were
were we're in a very unique and
unprecedented time right now where we've
never been so distracted and so tempted
by distraction so much so that we have
to erect all of these boundaries and go
way out of our way to protect and
construct time to to reflect and to kind
of engage with solitude whereas that was
just a byproduct of living in a bygone
era and you're somebody who's kind of at
the bleeding edge of this idea being of
paramount importance if you want to be
able to make the best decisions and and
you know live the best life that you're
capable of living you can't make good
decisions if you're constantly pulled in
a lot of different directions right and
today I think more than ever we're
distracted it's so easily available
you're in line at a grocery store you
pull out your phone you're texting
somebody you're always doing something
but like you said we're not reflecting
and if we think about learning one of
the key components of learning and how
we make decisions we learn and then we
apply that information is reflection and
we're losing the ability to reflect even
in what we consume online today a lot of
what we consume like we're just after
the soundbite or after the gist of it
just tell me tell me the summary
the book and we assume that if we get
the summary we understand what was in
the book yeah we assume that we we have
this knowledge and then we apply it and
it doesn't work and then we either blame
ourselves or stupid we're incompetent
and we're lazy whatever or we blame
other people or they're wrong they
didn't give us the right advice and then
we sort of like we lose the
responsibility angle to controlling our
own lives and we're not exploring I mean
traditionally I think what we're gonna
miss out on is exploring what it means
to live life and what it means to live
about our life and it's too late that we
realized that we might have been
distracted through all of life and then
we want to redo but there's no there's
no window at the end of luckily you get
one life and so you can't walk up at the
end and go oh you know what I wasted
that one let's do it again mm-hmm yeah I
think in tandem with that like looking
at it from 10,000 feet this is only
accelerating this you know this this
pace towards maximum distraction and we
become habituated to it so much so that
you know even myself who you know I'd
like to consider myself you know a
little bit having a little bit more
depth than somebody who's just scanning
headlines but I'll catch myself doing
that and thinking I got it like I'm
moving on to the next thing as I'm
scrolling through my Twitter feed and I
have to have this refrain like this
reminder that I need to step outside of
that silo in order to be you know fully
you know educated person I mean we all
do it it's how we respond when we catch
ourselves - and if we want to do it
that's fine but are we consciously doing
it or we unconsciously doing it I think
part of what I would like to encourage
is that we're more conscious about how
we spend our time and what we're
distracted with uh-huh how we go about
learning from our experiences like if
you think of learning going back to that
again most people think that you learn
just from experience you have an
experience and then you learn but that's
not how it works you need reflection and
from reflection you create an
abstraction the obstruction is what will
I do differently next time and then once
you have that then you put it into
action and you have this loop of
learning right so you have experience
reflection abstraction or what will I do
differently next time
and then you have an action and that
action comes to an experience and now
you have this circle that's full but if
we're not taking time to reflect we're
not learning until we're not sort of
progressing in life and we're not
thinking about what are the things I
want to do next year that are gonna make
my life better how can I live a better
life next year and we're always looking
for that sort of like quick win instead
of like what's the process to just
continuously like consciously think
about what it means to live live yeah I
think the action piece is the hardest
piece you know when I when I reflect on
my own decision-making patterns I think
of somebody who has a pretty
well-developed
self-awareness like I know when I'm
making the wrong decision and I'm aware
of the patterns that lead me astray and
yet I will catch myself perpetuating
them despite the self-awareness can you
like but you quit alcohol like have you
right I mean I have no no no I mean
there's certain yeah I have you know I
have made significant changes in my life
and and I believe myself to be on a you
know a trajectory of personal growth but
when I'm honest with myself and
objective about what I'm doing and what
I could do better
there are glaring examples of where you
know that growth there's still
tremendous growth that remains to be it
remains to be manifested but isn't that
our like perpetual state like state if
we want to get better I mean I think
happiness is sort of like the absence of
desire in the sense of like we don't
want to get better at things we don't
want more than we have we don't crave
these external validation we get it from
the inside flipside of that as like we
do strive for progress we strive to get
better and we sort of like we want to
live a more meaningful a better life
whatever that means to each of us and
there's no one answer to everybody it's
like here's how you live about our life
it's a question you have to explore
inside you uh-huh and that pushes us
forward and it's sort of like yeah sure
we catch ourselves doing something or
doing a behavior that we might not want
to do and then we have to let it go and
say like do I want to do it again or do
I just want to leave it there
right
in looking at kind of the work that you
do and and and what you put out into the
world to me it feels like here's a guy
who has this prodigious computer
scientist or you know oriented brain
that you know that sees things perceives
the world in a very like logical
rational way and you've taken that
acuity and you've placed it on top of
something that is extremely diffuse
amorphous and ephemeral and attempted to
create a road map to like canonize like
the best ideas out there to create this
lattice work to help us make better
ideas is that a fair representation of
how you approach your work yeah I think
so I mean like I did a computer science
degree I went to work for an
intelligence agency and then I realized
quickly over the years maybe two years
passed that my computer science degree
became less and less relevant and as I
made decisions that were less and less
technical and more people involved I
didn't have this sort of cannon of
knowledge from other disciplines or
domains to factor into how I was making
this decisions right so let's take it
back you you graduate University and you
end up as a cyber security computer
scientist that essentially Canada's
equivalent of the NSA Yeah right right
before 9/11 yeah it started two weeks
before September 11th that is crazy yeah
it was a terrible time right yeah a lot
of things happened a lot of I mean we
were super small at the time we grew
rapidly you ended up getting promoted
just because you're in the building
you're a body we need this work done and
so you did it even I mean I worked
probably six seven days a week you know
eight eight eight hours on the low end
10 to 12 on the high end for seven years
straight and can you talk can you speak
to what your role was there or is that
shrouding I think things they would
prefer I don't yeah yeah essentially
trying to make the world a safer place
oh yeah
right but I can imagine what it must
have been I mean how old were you like
23 24 or something like that
yeah 21 right this young person who gets
thrown into this situation and suddenly
it staffs up rapidly because of the you
know escalating threats and the
attention that you know this kind of
work requires and you find yourself in a
management position having to deal with
other people when you're used to you
know once and zeros on a keyboard yeah I
mean computers are great because you
tell it to do something the computer
always does it people work like that
people are different right like we're
biological so it's a very different sort
of thing for us where you can sort of
tell people like here's what I want to
happen and it doesn't necessarily happen
and then you have to think about well
this affects their family and a lot of
the decisions we were making not only
affected the family of the people we
worked with but they affected our
country they affected our country's
relationships with other countries they
affected troops in the theater they
affected civilians in war zones they
affected a lot of people and so you have
to consider this dynamic to a lot of the
decisions we are making and I do want to
say it was a great place to work right
like I get to work with some really
amazing world-class people and it's very
rare that you get to work with some of
the best in your field and they're there
because they love it not from the money
obviously
yes government but yeah but most people
in that circumstance would just they try
to make the best decisions they possibly
could they would you know run those
decisions by perhaps a you know trusted
few mentors or advisers to make sure
that they're kind of on the proper
trajectory but what you did I think is
is unusual in that you had the audacity
to take a step back and say wait a
minute like am I making the right
decision even if I'm being told that
it's fine like is this correct and how
can I you know create you know for lack
of a better word like a better algorithm
for how I'm making these decisions that
factor in all of these variables that
I'm trying to you know grok and track as
I move forward and upward
I felt I mean I felt the responsibility
of the decisions we were making at a
very personal level I mean my parents
are in the military mm-hmm
I could easily envision them overseas in
a war zone and what obligation do we
have to make great decisions and is good
enough good enough and what obligation
do I have as a person is there a stone
that I need to unturn is there something
I need to learn so that I can get
comfortable with it
what blindspots do I have so that I'm
you know sort of getting better at
making decisions or trying to and
granted all the decisions are somewhat
imperfect right and then judging
yourself on the outcome is really hard
because sometimes you it's like playing
poker right like sometimes you play your
hand perfectly and you can still lose
mm-hm and then how do you not take away
lessons from that or you get scared and
that also affects future decisions right
so it's it's a very complicated
environment to learn about
decision-making and exploring I ended up
going back in June my MBA so after
around 2007 I was like I need to learn
how to I need to get comfortable with
these decisions I need to get
comfortable with my process I need to
you sort of do the work that I need to
do to make better decisions and for me
to feel comfortable the decisions might
be the same but I'm not I'm not
comfortable that I sort of fully
understand and nobody did right like
we're all just doing the best we can
given the environment so the decision to
get an MBA wasn't motivated by some
sense that you were gonna become an
entrepreneur no not at all I need to
figure out how to like manage these
people better like what is it I did
definitely want to learn how to manage
you want to relate to people better and
do all that stuff stuff you don't
necessarily learn in computer science
right look you I was I spent years
debugging and coding and assembly and
doing all this stuff so I was very good
with computers and less good with people
and the MBA definitely helped with that
but the whole point of that was like I
went around the organization I started
following people to meetings I was like
I need to learn how decisions are really
bad and how I can make better decisions
and then I was like okay I've done that
now I like googled I did what everybody
does you know I googled like okay what
do I need to know but an MBA came up and
I was like I'm gonna go back and give my
name yeah
and then that proved simultaneously I
would say fruitful in the sense that it
put me on the path of Charlie Munger and
mental models and the flipside of that
was the degree I found you know pretty
easily
in schoolwork also right we're gonna get
to Charlie Munger but but prior to that
like you know the joke that I was gonna
make is well of course you then enrolled
for the class on how to make great
decisions and they handed you a textbook
and it was all laid out that's it yeah
right wouldn't life be awesome if
there's a class I'm like yeah here's
everything you need to know about
decision-making and and as if your work
highlights anything it's this you know
incredible lack of attention to this
very important skill in our educational
system that's premise on memorization
you know very much
you know breadth over depth and moving
forward quickly that doesn't really
prepare somebody for how to best
navigate the real world whether you're
in a job scenario or otherwise like how
are you thinking how are you making
decisions is there a better way to think
about you know these things that happen
in life so that you can set yourself up
for success yeah and it seems obvious
that that would be you know something
worthwhile for young people to ponder
and study well it's interesting right
because there is no class on
decision-making there's no skill called
decision-making decision-making is a
subset of skills I agree just like
there's no skill called reading reading
is a subset of skills right you take
words you put them into sentences you
take sentences new form meaning and
there's a whole bunch of different
skills involved and sort of reading the
same as decision making and nobody's
laid out I mean there are sort of
curriculums at Stanford and all of that
for classes on decision making but they
get very analytical very quickly and
real-world decision making often
involves sort of analytical side but
there's also emotional side there's also
sort of like second third order
consequences you need to think about
they don't necessarily stem from the
decision tree that you're creating right
and the interdisciplinary approach that
you've taken by looking at physics and
biology and you
these these somewhat seemingly distant
you know ways of looking at the world
and leveraging the wisdom and the laws
of those you know of those disciplines
into how you make decisions in the real
world yeah it's a work in progress but
it's still definitely trying to
incorporate that yeah because this
wisdom is out there it's you're not
inventing these things out of whole
cloth by performing experiments on human
beings you're just sort of looking
canvassing the world and saying here's
what the smartest people in the world
have said over the ages dating back to
you know the Stoics are you know I don't
know how far back you've gone you know
all the way back through you know
mythology to the latest and greatest of
you know physics and biology to kind of
divine greater truths that can inform
how we navigate the world yeah I don't
think anything I've done or we've done
on the website or anything that we've
made public is original content it's
sort of like we are just going back to
these sort of timeless ideas and one of
the reasons they're timeless is we keep
keep being able to apply them to
everyday life right and if we can learn
the timeless ideas that knowledge
doesn't expire so much of what we
consume today is no longer valuable in a
week so what if we just build more depth
around the things that are timeless
because those are the things that are
likely to impact us again in the future
likely to come up so enter Charlie
Munger yeah sue Charlie Munger's so the
the the version of how I got put onto
Munger I think I've read something about
Buffett in like 2000 and then during the
MBI week we end up doing a case study in
class mm-hmm and there's like six groups
presenting and we're the last group and
all of these other I'm like panicking
because all these other groups have a
very different answer on this case study
that we do and we get up there and our
team leaders sort of like speaks and
he's like well you know we thought about
it differently and gave our sort of
response to the position we were put in
and the teacher the professor I guess
would said you didn't do the work and
he's like no actually we did do the work
we just sort of like had a different
interpretation of it and hear all the
reasons that we had a different
interpretation here's why we think all
the the
five groups answers would not work and
they got into this like a verbal spot
hmm and he I remember he just walked out
like he said I'm done the professor or
no no this student like our team leader
said he walked out he said I'm done and
what he meant was he was done with the
MBA program he literally went back to
Italy is his room packed up his bags and
I ran ran into him in the cafeteria
after that and I was like how did like
what we did made sense to me right like
I don't understand how they like what
did we do differently and he just put me
under Charlie Munger and I remember
going back to my dorm room that night
and just googling Munger and then that
was the next went down a rabbit hole oh
yeah I mean I stopped doing schoolwork
basically I started diving into you
mongers way of thinking which is sort of
how do we apply these natural laws to
give us a tailwind
right and how do we work with the world
instead of against the world mm-hmm a
couple things I mean first of all it's
not surprising that you know thinking
outside the box was not rewarded but it
is I think noteworthy that in the
context of an NBA program you would
think that a creative approach to
problem-solving would be something that
would that you know would warrant
recognition so here's my theory on this
and I don't know if it's accurate but
the MBA programs are so expensive now
they're they're you know 75 200 thousand
dollars a lot of them are made by
corporations corporation right that's
why they're so expensive now so
corporations won't send people that
people are failing so teachers rely or
professors realize that they again this
is my theory that they can't really fail
people and so they just optimize for
what's easiest right what's easiest for
me now is like less about teaching and
it doesn't happen at every program and
I'm I'm generalizing but this is sort of
my hypothesis from talking to a lot of
people who've done MBAs and they feel
very similar in the sense that to some
level that teachers are optimizing for
okay well I can't actually get involved
because I can't give people real grades
so because I can't do that I'm gonna
step back and if I'm gonna step back
then I'm just gonna sort of like slowly
get back to the path of least resistance
which is like everybody passes
a signal that you did the work and we're
okay I think that that means that that's
a system that could use a little first
order thinking it could definitely use a
lot of minute but I noticed last year I
think MBA enrollments went down for the
first time in a long time so maybe maybe
that'll be a cause for them to OHANA so
this discovery of Munger puts a chilling
effect on your enthusiasm for your MBA
program yeah but it also I mean it made
it more valuable in a lot of ways right
because when we were doing accounting
you start connecting everything together
instead of just learning these separate
subjects you start realizing that the
world is just connected like everything
is connected you can't you can't work in
an organization or lead somebody and ask
them to do something without recognizing
that that might affect their home life
or without recognizing that maybe
they're in a bad mood today because
something happened at home and they're
bringing that to the workplace and if
you're asking them to stay late you're
borrowing from the future and when you
borrow from the future you sort of like
have to give that back and like how you
accomplish things matters too and so you
start sort of like connecting all these
different subjects which is like the map
is not the territory which is one of the
mental models we write in the book is
like binary first one right so financial
statements are a great example of sort
of maps right that they point out sort
of how business is operating at least on
the surface but it doesn't tell the real
story about what's happening below the
surface and we've seen this from the
likes of Enron right where all these
financial statements are public and they
look great but below the surface the
terrain not the map the actual terrain
is much different and it speaks to sort
of problems and so you you learn how
these things can sort of like play out
and then you sort of watch organizations
that are run on dashboards and it's
really interesting because dashboards
are Maps right they just want all the
indicators to be green or the numbers to
be a certain number and that doesn't
necessarily like a lot of the times
what's happening below the surface is
you're borrowing from the future and you
don't realize you're borrowing from the
future so the terrain is actually
different than the mapping right and the
the the utility of the map is directly
related to your understanding of its
limitations and pitfalls right and the
great example if you want to
conceptualize this as set of financial
statements is online date
right you get a profile of somebody
that's a map of who they are and then
you meet them in person and it's often a
very different story than the impression
you often you're single now right I am
okay yeah I mean I'm not on those apps
but it seems like that's sort of the
unanimous case it's a crazy stories like
people show up they're like a different
race they indicate it's like what the
heck
right I don't do a better job so
understanding that going in before you
swipe left or whatever it is that you do
to say you're interested in know the
utility of that is understanding that
whoever's on the other side of that is
probably not going to be an accurate
reflection of whatever you're seeing and
read right now definitely yeah so so I
take it then that the fascination with
monger isn't just you know sort of his
his his individual unique insights about
business and investing it's this it's
the connectivity of all of these ideas
and how they they can work together to
create you know use this word
latticework you know this interplay of
ideas that create almost like an
assembly line for how you engage with
decision making yeah I think mugger was
the first person that pointed it out but
there's others that have sort of like
taking up the mantle since him like
Peter bevel and and Peter Kaufman and to
some extent Warren Buffett although he
doesn't talk in that way he definitely
thinks in that way uh-huh and I think
what's happening is here's an example of
people that are applying this in their
real world not in the theory not in sort
of like a classroom they're actually
using this information to make better
decisions they're not perfect but
they're using the information to make
better decisions about what matters
right and like incentives would be a
great example so incentives drive a ton
of behavior we spend a bit 12 13 minutes
on incentives in my MBA program but if
you were to talk to people and you were
to talk to anybody who runs a business
or an entrepreneur and they know just
how valuable incentives are that would
be something worth exploring like what
type of incentive system should you
create how are they gamed what does it
mean to create a good incentive system
should you have different
systems for different levels in the
organization should everybody be able to
articulate the incentive system how do
incentive systems go wrong yeah I think
unhealthy incentives are at the heart of
so many systemic ills right now
politically financially socially etc and
they just they're they're perpetuated
too I think that the the great at great
cost to everybody yeah definitely and it
was changing incentives is hugely
powerful but you can also unleash
potential right if you give people
freedom redirecting those yes and they
say no what the incentives are and the
your incentives are aligned and you
often get into problems or because it's
easy to create financial incentives and
a lot of organizations are purely
financial but what if your your
organization values other things too
right like they value the environment or
they value all of these other things and
then you you have multiple I wouldn't
say conflicting incentives but people
are overthinking and it's not clear what
they need to do you can't talk about
incentives without talking about bias
right definitely
and then bias is an interesting thing is
you have Daniel Kahneman who's one
basically you know a Nobel laureate out
of this and he studied bias his whole
life and when I was talking to him on
our show like on the podcast he's he
basically said like I'm no better at
avoiding bias this is the great
disheartening irony and all of it like
the guy who's pine who sort of this
pioneer of exploring the limits of
rationality and human beings and has a
tremendous amount of self-awareness
around it still is the first to say that
it has had very little impact on his own
decision-making yeah I mean it's kind of
scary in a way right because what we do
is we convince ourself that oh if I just
create a list of biases and this was
something that came up at my MBA program
and something I've seen people apply to
varying degrees of success but they
create a list of biases like ah I might
overconfident am i using short term
information versus long term information
did I recently acquire this information
therefore I'm more prone to overvalue it
etc and they think that if they go
through the checklist that they they
avoid the biases but what really happens
is usually if you're intelligent enough
create the checklist in the first place
you just start telling yourself better
stories about why that bias doesn't i'm
not overconfident in this case because
right and they are that story gets
better the smarter you are and more
convincing you can convince yourself and
so it doesn't actually sort of help us
avoid that yeah intelligence becomes an
Achilles heel on that in that context
right
yeah in in 12-step they always say like
you know the the the hyper intelligent
people have the hardest time because
they they just come up with a million
reasons why the steps are [ __ ] and
how they're not going to work and all of
that as opposed to just just
surrendering to it and just doing it and
realizing the results of that and this
is like an analogous case where if
you're hyper intelligent you're gonna be
able to do perform the mental you know
gymnastics required to rationalize
whatever it is you've already decided to
do I think I remember listening to you
is prepped for this where you you had
said something along the lines of it was
only when you you followed the
directions sort of like blindly yeah
like let go of all of that yeah you have
to there's a you have to really humble
yourself yeah I think to get to that
place yeah and when you're in pain it's
easier to do that but but yeah if you go
in and you think these people don't know
what they're talking you know like I I
know this is nonsense or whatever and
you're gonna you think you have a better
idea that's where you see a lot of
unnecessary struggle well that's the
curse of sort of intelligence in a way
right is like you're in the meeting at
work and you always think you can
improve the value of the idea and I
remember one of the things I had to
learn as a manager was somebody would
come up with an idea and the idea would
be 90% correct and I would spend a lot
of time and this is my failing right I
would spend time going like oh well
here's how you make it from 90 to 95 but
what would happen I didn't realize that
at the time at least not the first few
times is that the motivation on the
person's part would fall from a hundred
percent motivation where they owned the
idea and it was a ninety percent
solution to maybe like 50 percent mmm
but we the solution would be sort of
like five percent better
if you will mm-hmm but the outcome would
be way worse and so what was happening
is that you're adding too much value to
it it's it's sort of similar to what
you're talking about right where you're
trying to add value to the process but
the process is proven to work the
motivation of the people that are in the
meetings is here's my idea I want to do
it and maybe you get to that 90% and
then you can add value to it but you
sort of like have to let them run with
that and don't have to let them go with
that right so you finish your MBA you go
back to the Intelligence Agency yeah and
you're leading the Charlie Munger
fanclub at this point definitely okay
actually I had an anonymous vlog at this
point yeah when did when did you did you
start the blog when you were still in in
Business School or when you returned to
intelligence no I suspect you were
working in tandem when you were going
school yeah yeah it was working
full-time good in school full-time
uh-huh because I made why not right now
of course and I started the the website
as a means to keep track of what I was
learning and so the original website was
six eight 131 - I think 14 40
blogger.com and the reason it was that
is six eight 131 is the zip code for
Berkshire Hathaway and 1448 believes
their unit number in cube Plaza and it
was never intended for anybody else
right only a computer scientist would
come up with that URL well it was like
oh yeah I would type that right right
like nobody will find it why not just
Journal but why even make it publicly
available because I like computers and
journals like I had to take with me and
then I would have to like look up things
and I couldn't hyperlink and connect
ideas and the whole point of Munger was
sort of like connecting the world got it
the flip side of this is I worked for an
intelligence agency and having any
public profile is sort of not a good
idea right to varying degrees was there
even like a little bio blurb that said
I'm anonymously writing this because I
work in an intelligence agency yeah that
would be Pat Neff no cuz it wasn't for
anybody else Yeah right it was literally
just for me and it was so there was no
information about who was behind it it
was just this anonymous webs like I
would say almost completely anonymous at
the time and then over the years people
found it and then it became sort of
or uh Nenana miss if you will was there
an inflection point where suddenly you
realize like this is being consumed by a
bunch of people I think in like
2013-2014 I started to take it a lot
more seriously and you still had the zip
code URL I think we changed that in 2012
maybe 2013 to Farnam Street blog calm
and now if it's a fast blog right I'm
but yeah uh-huh yeah there was a moment
where I sort of I knew I had to put a
name behind it to do the things I wanted
to do and that was a big turning point
right not only because I was still
working for an intelligence agency and I
was basically like about to cause a
ruckus on the inside because I'm gonna
have a very did they know did you have
to tell them that you were doing this
you need a when you're working in that
kind of a place do you need approval to
even speak publicly at all about
anything
um they definitely prefer that it's a
little murky as to whether you need
approval but I mean I wasn't talking
about anything to do with work nothing
no I was no anecdotes no stories no it
wasn't what were they aware that you
were doing it or were you just keeping
that on the DL well a lot of people
there used to read it when it was
anonymous interestingly enough right and
so I had this weird backdoor influence
into the organization where the most
senior levels of the organization were
reading my website and having no idea
that they'd have no idea where I was
that I was like I remember literally my
boss came to me today and he was like
you should read this article yeah he
sent me sent me my own article I was
like yeah okay he seems pretty switched
I had to be I mean that's somewhat
surreal but also that had to arm you
with confidence that you know perhaps
you could take this leap and go do this
thing yeah I mean it's also a testament
to the people I was working with right
lower they're always looking to get
better and they're always going to grow
and make make better decisions and the
website turned out to be sort of about
decision-making leadership and just some
extent innovation and now it's morphed
into more of like all of that plus like
how can we live a better life because
they're all incorporated and
and when you when you you know really
cottoned onto this way of thinking like
did that I presume that had a positive
impact on how you were managing people
and you were you were able to kind of
see and perhaps even quantify the
results I think I got better as a
manager but I mean I started out from a
terrible base to you right I have his
head turned I can only go up yeah pretty
much like I don't know where bottom
would have been from that but it's
interesting sort of getting better as
you go along and just if you think about
it you're you're sort of like your slope
or your trajectory matters a lot more
than where you start from
and so my I started from way worse spot
managing I didn't have any of the people
skills that other people come in with I
didn't have that thinking by default and
so I started from a lower base but I
think I got to a better place in the end
because of just constant progress mm-hmm
yeah I think all of our brains function
and operate on on a set of models that
that were largely not consciously aware
of right it's not that it's not that
they're there were just free associating
and making decisions willy-nilly
we're defaulting to a set of pathways
and parameters that we've we've sort of
habituated to over time based on
experience or school or what have you
that almost seemed like there it's just
you know it's on kind of an autopilot
yeah as opposed to taking a beat and and
really stepping outside of that and and
trying to deconstruct how you arrived at
a certain decision and then you know
questioning or applying that to a
different set of parameters to see if
you get a different outcome so much of
decision making is pattern matching and
you match the patterns based on the
information you have in your head and so
much about better decision making is
delaying that intuition of pattern
matching we're recognizing it and sort
of like not acting on it in the moment
so when did you arrive at this idea that
you were gonna try to take all of this
information and and try to create you
a better pattern or latticework out of
it as opposed to I'm I'm posting blog
posts here and there but actually
looking at it from a broader you know
perspective to say there's a bigger
there's a bigger opportunity here to do
something substantial and meaningful
that it seems like no one else had
really ever done probably 2015 I mean
the idea sort of wasn't mine and came
from Munger right he's like you just
need to learn the big ideas from all of
these different disciplines and I was
like oh and then I googled that and it's
not available and I'm like why can't I
make that available right like this is
the education that I want to do for
myself over time and obviously it's a
it's a destination you never really
reach is just something you sort of like
get better at incrementally and I just
thought I would sort of create that for
the world
and and at what point do you get in your
car and drive to Nebraska and knock on
Charlie's door Oh funny yeah yeah have
you met him I have met him yeah you have
met him okay good I'm glad
yeah I'm actually going to see him
tomorrow oh you are at the dilly journal
meeting so what does he what is he
thinking about thousand other people Wow
that's cool
what does he think about all this stuff
that you're doing oh I have no idea he's
probably not even aware really oh come
on yeah I'm sure he does well he knows
that you're you've written this book and
that you cite his work and all of that
right
he's got a copy of the book so okay
alright I think he's just you know he's
97 now right I know right yeah yeah yeah
as a reverent and sort of as ever but
right so at some point you decide I'm
gonna put cyber security and
intelligence in the rearview and I'm
gonna do this full-time and I think it's
interesting to kind of spend a few
minutes talking about how you you reckon
with what could be considered to be you
know an intuitive decision or one coming
more from the heart like I think about
some of the decisions that I've made
that have had the biggest impact on my
trajectory for better or worse and and
many of them were made
you know without a lot of information
and and no conscious modeling but really
we're kind of heart centered you know
like I have a passion for this thing and
like I'm gonna go for it and it doesn't
make sense like if I was to map that on
to your you know models it would have
seemed like a terrible idea and yet in
retrospect perhaps it was the the best
thing that I could have done and you
kind of walking away from a secure
career path to you know step into this
new vocation this Wild West space I
would imagine you know I you know how
did that map onto how you think about
decision making well oh everybody else
thought I was crazy right - my parents
are like you're walking away from not
only basically a predetermined career
path that'll get you wherever you want
to go and a huge like great salary in
comparison to anything they ever made
and a stable pension and security and
you know it's a government job so it's
very hard to sort of like lose your job
and you're just willing to give all of
that up to pursue your dreams and I
think the answer to that is yeah I mean
I would rather sort of my personal take
on this is I would rather fall short in
life pursuing my dreams then spend the
rest of my life regretting not pursuing
my dreams and I think that I believe in
myself and I also believe like I didn't
I didn't have a lot as a kid I didn't I
mean I didn't want for anything and
there's kids who had way worse life than
I did but I knew I could always go back
to zero and I would be okay mm-hmm and
if it meant that I had to go get a job
working for somebody else again I would
figure it and I believe that and I also
knew at the end of the day I could go
back to the Intelligence Agency within a
reasonable time period so I took a year
off a leave of absence for a year uh-huh
so you you could have gone back if it I
could have gone back and ran I'm you
know I still have a top-secret clearance
so are you at the end of the day I'm
pretty sure I get if i needed to i get
all right but that's neither here nor
there right like i think i impact that
space in a different way
you know yeah right and that that that
superior who said hey you should read
this article at what point did you tell
him that that was you I think he was a
few yeah okay it wasn't long because
then I felt that right like I felt like
I was sort of even though I wasn't in on
it I felt like I was deceiving him and I
didn't want to be in a relationship I
felt like I was deceiving
yeah because I knew something he didn't
know about it and then it was at that
point that I think he unsubscribed after
I told him to feel he started
second-guessing his own yeah yeah yeah
that's funny well what you build is
amazing your your your website isn't you
know it's just an absolute treasure
trove of incredibly valuable information
that's just freely available including
all of the mental models like you've got
this beautiful book out now the great
mental models it's like Volume one you
know starting with general thinking
concepts like nine of you know nine of
the initial mental models in this but
you can get blurbs of all of them on
your website okay right so what's going
to happen is we decided to undertake
this project it's a three to four year
project we're sort of in the middle of
it right now we're gonna release four
volumes of the book the book is going to
contain the big ideas from all the
disciplines there'll be about a hundred
and thirteen of them at the end of the
day we summarized them on the website
we're gonna release the books and then
at some point in the future we'll make
all the content freely available for
everybody because one of the things that
I believe in is sort of like equalizing
opportunity not necessarily outcomes but
opportunity and I think making that
thinking sort of like available free
online is a good thing to do for the
world
yeah but it's been I mean as we were
talking about earlier publishing a book
has been quite an ordeal right because
we're acting as the publisher spewing at
all right like we have a graphic
designer and we have a creative director
and we have a printer in Latvia that
we're dealing with and then we have
Amazon issues where you know we have a
distributor but Amazon's trying to order
more copies and we're like well that's
all we printed and like don't sell more
than that right you go to the Amazon and
yeah well you did I mean you did a
beautiful job I had you just handed this
to me before the podcast I was I have
the Kindle version which I'm about 45
percent into at the moment and I'm
really enjoying it but the tactile
experience of this book like it's it's
it's beautifully put together and you
know a couple observations I mean first
on the subject of of self-publishing
which i think is absolutely the right
decision for this kind of book people
think well remove the gatekeepers and
you can just you can just put it out
there which is true but you also have to
understand that you're gonna this is a
you're starting a new business and
you're gonna have to project manage like
a million variables in order to like
make it happen it's not it's not a small
thing and especially to create a book of
this you know caliber I mean there's
there's a lot of you know very detailed
design aspects to this with you know
inserted color pages and tons of
illustrations and you know color
lithographs and things like that like
it's it's unique in that on the one hand
it's it operates sort of like a textbook
like and the the title kind of lends
itself to that like it's there's nothing
there's no click Beatty you know title
or anything to grab you it's like this
is sort of a manual a primer and yet
it's also very easily digestible like
it's very plain spoken it's not
difficult to read you these principles
these models by way of you know
historical anecdotes etc to elucidate
the concepts and and that makes it like
fun to read but also like it's like this
perfect combination of you know the
sweet and the South in the sour like
like giving you your vegetables and your
dessert at the same time think yeah I
had somebody email me and say it was the
most boring title ever to make the Wall
Street Journal bestselling last great
mental model general thinking and no
small thing to make to make the Wall
Street Journal bestseller list as a
self-published book like not very many
people accomplish that yeah we're lucky
to have a big audience and I think what
it's a reference book right so just put
people in the context of it it's
designed to be a reference book it's not
designed to be it's
like a popular book it's not designed to
be something you sit down and read and
an afternoon it's meant to be it's
almost like my testament to the old
Encyclopedia Brittanica or something
right like it's beautifully designed and
it's meant to be picked up and sort of
explored as you need it and when you
need it and I'm glad you like it
yeah no it's really it's really cool so
the idea is you're gonna do five of
these for ice we're gonna do five but I
think we're gonna condense the last ones
together right well I think it would be
good to kind of go through maybe a
couple of these mental models so that we
can better understand them first but why
don't you you know it probably would be
good to define what you mean by a methyl
bottle yeah model it's just a
representation in our head of how
something works it's on a testament to
whether it's good or bad or true or
false it's just how we we conceptualize
an idea and use it to think and it helps
us determine if you think about how you
approach problems you're using this
toolbox of mental models and you have in
your head and it determines what you
think is relevant the variables you
think are relevant how those variables
are going to interact over time and what
the likely outcome is going to be and so
the better the tools you have for the
particular situation you have the better
your thinking is likely to be the better
you're going to interconnect those
things over time and you'd better you'll
understand sort of the second and
third-order consequences of the decision
mm-hmm and it's kind of a tiered set up
right like this first book is about you
know these general thinking concepts
which are kind of required to fully
understand before you can drill down
into some of the more detailed models
that that that come from a variety of
different disciplines yeah it's the next
volume is sort of physics chemistry and
biology and then we're going to go from
there but we're not connecting them yet
so the point of the books is like the
models are pretty independent they're
connected a little bit and then after
the books are released
we'll use the internet to connect them
because we want people to connect them
themselves because when you do the work
yourself to connect the ideas it has a
more powerful bond that if I point them
out for you I mean will do the work for
you but we're sort of like doing it in
stages
with the goal of having people learn how
to apply them as they go along how do
you think about not being overwhelmed
though like you have a hundred and nine
of these and then within them there's
corollaries and like sort of sub sub
models within the model Rea so alright I
have to make this decision you know like
what am I supposed to do like run this
through a hundred and nine different
ways of looking at it before I have
clarity that I'm you know conviction
that I'm making the right decision well
that's an interesting question right
because I think to some extent the
answers depends on the decision right
and how much you like so often today we
put weight into being decisive we put
weight into being a knowledge worker we
put weight into deciding on the spot no
matter the type of decisions but if
we're making sort of an irreversible
consequential decision then yeah I mean
we want to take our time we want to go
through maybe we do want to go through a
checklist of 109 it's sort of like the
big ideas in the world and see which
one's apply and which ones don't and
then use those to remove our blind spots
but the idea or another way to phrase
that would be walk around the problem in
a three-dimensional way but if we're
making sort of an inconsequential
reversible decision and we probably just
want to go with our gut or we want to
delegate it to somebody else or those
decisions don't matter as much so the
way that we approach each decision
should vary by the weight of the
decision or the consequences or the
reversal reversibility of the decision
itself but the first decision would have
to be is this a consequential decision
or an inconsequential decision yeah
right it reversible or is that are
several principles that's sort of how I
approach job Patrick Collison approaches
it the same way I think he talked on our
podcasts about how they make different
decisions based on reversibility of the
decisions Jeff Bezos calls it one way
door versus two way door and so like
they're all thinking in terms of like
irreversible decisions need to be made
in a different way right like if you're
if you're making a decision that you you
can't back out of then you probably do
want to think through it you want to
take I mean one of the pieces of advice
that we give people is like just take
their
and go for a walk and just think about
it what is that doing it's delaying
intuition if you have the models in your
head you can sort of like think through
it well am I using a map here what's the
Matt Mead am I like familiar enough with
the Train is it within my circle of
competence or outside of my circle of
competence if it's outside of my circle
of competence do I know somebody who has
that in their circle of competence can I
talk to them about it and when you talk
to them about it the way that you talk
to them about it coming back to how we
learn again
you want to talk to them about it from
the point of understanding not from a
point of what to do so often we approach
people and we're like what would you do
in this situation and I think that
there's a value in that but there's a
lot more value in saying how would you
think about this problem what are the
variables that come to mind for you how
do those variables interact and then
what would you do and how confident are
you in this you know in this specialty
right to evaluate the weight of that
advice that you're gonna be given right
but one of the models in the book is
circle of copper eyes right so if the
decision is within your circle of
competence trusting your gut is probably
reasonable you want to check in but your
guide is probably right if it's outside
of your circle of competence then you
your gut probably has less relevance
than if it was within I think it
obviously has less relevance than if it
was within and so now you want to
instead of checking it you want to go oh
well who do I know that has more
information or better information on
this than I do how can I approach them
and are those three or four people
because if there's three or four people
now I can triangulate right so I can ask
you what variables matter I can ask
somebody else what variables matter and
I can ask somebody else and then between
them where's the overlap and what are
they different those are probably the
areas to explore about what's going to
impact that decision and what you have
to keep an eye on and then you don't
always have to make decisions in a way
that you're making a full decision so
often we look at the decision as the
decision but you can often break
decisions into smaller decisions and
gather information and that information
can change the path right like you you
don't have to do decide to invade a
country right you can decide that oh we
want to scope out information we want to
scout we want to do all this other
things that are short of sort of like
the big decision
we we wrap a lot of our ego up into
making those big decisions because we
want to be the person who makes those
big decisions yeah and the ego creates a
gigantic blind spot yeah for a lot of
people probably most people all of us to
some degree right like Ryan wrote ego is
the enemy but it's also your friend
right like there's two sides of this ego
coin which is it propels us to do things
that have never been done before I mean
the reason that you want to put people
on Mars is because you think you can do
it but nobody's ever done it before so
there's a large component of ego there
mmm-hmm but when is it serving you when
is it getting in your way
yeah when you think I mean you know
obviously Elon Musk is the embodiment of
many of these models you know first
principle thinking and also somebody
who's who's you know circle of
competence is very wide and yet you know
to land a rocket you know that is that
inside his circle of con you know it's
these things become blurred I would
imagine part of this is is having self
awareness around the boundaries of that
circle in order to you know properly you
know calibrate when you need to you know
check your thinking with somebody else
so your circle can expand and it can
become a relevant - right so you can
grow it or if it's a rapidly moving
field if you're not keeping up to date
at shrinks and so I think you'll ins a
great example of somebody who's grown
his in multiple domains or year probably
in ways that most of us would never
would never do right he's slept at his
office he's dedicated his whole life to
these things he's he's all-in on these
projects and he's been all-in for years
right I think he's been basically Tesla
and SpaceX for the past 12 years and
there's not much else and most of us
when we look at that we're I wouldn't
trade I wouldn't do that right like I
want to have more time with my family I
want to sleep more nights I don't want
to be jet-setting around the world
nobody's jet-lagged I don't want to be
doing all of these things and I think I
think the world needs more people like
you on yeah thank God we got an Elan
yeah but we also can't sit back and just
expect he's gonna do it all for us right
I don't know man yeah I'm waiting for
his next Friday
right let's talk about inversion that's
an interesting one yeah so like what do
you want to avoid right often we don't
know that we don't know the answer we
don't know sort of the best path but we
know the outcomes we want to avoid right
so let's get rid of the bad outcomes and
we're only left with the good outcomes
or another way to think of that is often
organizations work on stories it's the
story we tell that gets us promoted what
are you doing so it's an addition thing
it's like you're in charge of innovation
on the organization and so you have to
tell a story about all the things you're
doing at the organization that are
making the organization more innovative
and it becomes about that story when
becoming more innovative might be asking
yourself what are the things we're doing
that are getting in the way of
innovation and then removing those but
that's not a good story you can tell
right we have too many meetings and
meetings are too long that like you know
people aren't they don't feel trusted
they don't feel like they can share
ideas they don't feel loved or respected
they don't like all of this how do we
improve those those are one angle to it
but the other angle is like what are the
things we're doing that are getting in
the way of trust so instead of trying to
improve it like what's a roading it is
it a values massage between what we say
our values and what we're living and
that creates a conflict where people
listen to the I mean we're more prone to
listen to the environment than we are to
words so if the culture the stated
culture of the organization was one
thing but the other culture is a
different thing then we listen to that
and then we become scared when we come
scared we don't want to collaborate and
we don't feel loved we don't feel
respected and that's communicating with
our subconscious so why would we how do
we sort of like go all in on this
project or for this organization when
we're getting this these mismatched
signals and a large part of life is sort
of like I think Charlie Munger who
phrased it like I just want to know
where I'm gonna die so I never go there
and that's inversion right like how do
we avoid that outcome and you can also
imply inversion to life right if you
it's a great thought experiment to sort
of think about where you like close your
eyes and think about where you are when
you're 90 you're sitting on a bench and
you're
the end of your life it's your last day
like what do you want your eulogy to say
what do you want people to say about you
do you want people to say that you you
were the CEO of a fortune 500 company
but you had no friends because the way
that you attained that was mutually
exclusive from meaningful relationships
with others do you want people to say
that you were always there as a father a
spouse a partner and then are you living
a life in accordance with that right so
how do I avoid the outcomes that I don't
want right so now I know what I do want
have a vector how do I get there well I
just start dropping away these things
that are getting in the way of that
right maybe I don't I give up sort of
trying to make partner at a law firm and
that's okay because that's not really
what I want so much of what we want we
think we want it in the moment but when
we get it we're no happier we're no
better I mean I fell into this when I
was getting promoted I always thought oh
the next promotion I'll just be happier
I'll be so much I can impact the
organization more I I will make more
money so I can live a better life but it
never seemed to manifest itself right no
matter how much money I made or where
what level I got to in the organization
there was always sort of this your peer
group changes and now you're just
comparing yourself to new people and you
don't feel good about it and I think
that keeping the end in mind which is
inverting when let's live life backwards
what does that mean to live life
backwards it means that we're living
towards that goal so we can filter on a
day-to-day basis and avoid this stuff
that gets in the way of where we
actually want to go right so inversion
bringing clarity to all of this by by
basically forecasting all the way to the
end point and moving backwards from
there to better understand the steps
that you want to take that we're going
to move you in the direction that you
want to go the the the kind of bug that
I see in the system that you kind of
touched on here for a second is I think
that most people really don't know what
they want yeah
or they think they know what they want
but it's not really what they want
your example of thinking that you wanted
to be promoted and this would provide
you with happiness or whatever it else
you were seeking in that moment getting
that only to realize that wasn't the fix
or that that was a misplaced
you know expectation on your part and so
much of I think proper decision-making
is rooted in the internal process of
self-reflection like it's a it's an
emotional spiritual journey where you
have to become adequately integrated and
self actualized in order to even set
that vector to begin with yeah
appropriate direction I don't know if I
can add yeah like it's true right like
nobody's ever taught you how to reflect
nobody's ever or very few people ever
sort of like sit down in life and say
like where do you want to go like are
you doing the things that you are gonna
we're so busy we're so focused on speed
and the difference between speed and
velocity is velocity has a destination
that has a vector attached to it so
you're going somewhere you're not
running around in circles and we're so
busy up until the point where it's too
late and then we realize that we sort of
often realize that we didn't spend our
time the way we wanted to spend it but
if you know what you want people to say
when you're 90 you know what that
outcome is you know what that
destination is which involves sitting
down and thinking about it and
struggling with it and knowing that that
answer is not the same for everybody
right there are people who want money
power and fame and they'll walk over
other people to get there so it's not a
judgement on that but do you know where
you're going do you know how to get
there are you thinking about it
consciously and are you living a life
that's in line with that and I think
that those are really important
questions to explore and not just once
you've explored them as you live right
like as we were talking about earlier
some things change right what you think
you want when you're 20 is very
different than say 30 or 40 or 50 or 60
in right so you always have to be
checking in with that but back to
incentives I think that we're we're in a
culture where those incentives are
misplaced we're not incentivized to do
that kind of internal reflection you
know short of suffering a personal
crisis that compels us to look in the
mirror in a different way it's the rare
individual who will step outside of the
you know structure in which they find
themselves in order to really take stock
you know in a very honest way of where
they're at and where they really really
truly want to be what bigger incentive
though can you have then you get one
life and the opportunity cost of life
but you're you only get one you're born
and then you're sent to school and
you're you know on the receiving end of
a tremendous amount of information and
inputs and you're driving around and
you're looking at billboards and you're
watching television and it's impossible
to not have all of that you know
influence how you prioritize how you're
gonna live it's a materialistic culture
we're told that luxury and comfort our
priorities that we should climb the
corporate ladder that we should grind
and work harder than the person sitting
next to us and you know impress the boss
and you know get get the new car lease
and you know move to the suburbs or
whatever it is without without ever
taking a moment to stop and and and
apply a mental model to that well I mean
it's easy to live your life by somebody
else's scorecard it's hard to live your
life by your own scorecard but only one
of those is likely to make you satisfied
mm-hmm yeah and I think it's it's it's a
personal responsibility thing it's
incumbent upon all of us to take
responsibility for wrestling with those
those questions for ourselves but it's
in plain sight right if you you do the
research on regrets of the nearly dead
the people in old-age homes that are at
the end of it alive they all sort of
regret the same things you know but we
all know that right so this is this this
elucidates another thing that you talk a
lot about which is the difference
between knowledge and understanding and
the gap that exists between
understanding and action like we all
know that story of being on the deathbed
and how the person never says I wish I
worked harder yeah right but does that
really impact how we're living our lives
on the daily basis what is the
trickle-down impact of that and I think
it speaks to another model the specific
title which I can't recall but it has to
do with
[Music]
when when the outcomes of your actions
are very are very distant from yeah
what's that one called
first-order second-order to thinking I
think so but it's a maybe it's a
corollary that like where the further
away the impact of your actions are the
easier it is to just you know sort of
absolve yourself of responsibility for
those decisions
yeah the distance from that is I mean
one of the reasons that we we don't
learn from our decision-making that we
talk about in the book is sort of like
the distance from the decisions so if
you're communicating through two or
three people before the somebody
actually puts it into action you
convince yourself that your decision was
right it's just the execution was flawed
whereas if you put your hand on a hot
stove there's nobody else to blame 100%
an ability when you throw a plastic bag
in the garbage it's hard to tie that to
culpability for for global climate
change well when you buy a stake at the
grocery store you're so disconnected
there's so many people in between that
state being in the grocery store and the
person that you know slit the cow's
throat that you don't feel like you
really have any you're not you're not
wed to that that choice or if you eat a
Snickers bar every day right like today
it's not gonna make a difference but you
do that every day for 10 years and it's
probably gonna make a huge difference so
not only how your body processes sort of
that food and your insulin response but
it'll make a difference to your weight
your overall health and your probably
your happiness yeah and tying it back to
the elderly person lying on their
deathbed yeah I get that but like you
know what like I got this deadline and
you know the boss is waiting for this
thing and I'm just gonna have to pull an
all-nighter I mean you can live your
life one day at a time if you're gonna
do that you might as well go get high on
like heroin or something right like it
doesn't it doesn't equate to sort of
like where do I want to be when I am at
the end of my life and we don't know if
we're gonna die today or we're gonna die
tomorrow or when life is gonna end and
so you sort of have to maximize for
happiness in the moment but plan for
living forever right one of my favorite
of your models or sub models is this
idea of first-order negatives in
exchange for
second-order positives yeah so going to
the gym is a great example right I don't
like going to the gym some people like
it but it's not my you know it's not my
favorite I don't wake up and go yeah I
get to go to the gym today but it's
something I do because it's gonna it's
increases the odds that I'm gonna have a
happy healthy longer life right it
releases stress it has numerous health
benefits to not only my brain but my
body increases the odds that I'm going
to be healthy but for me it's a
first-order negative I don't want to go
to the gym and I do it because I know
that the payoffs are sort of positive in
the end or at least they're
probabilistically positive I got a pithy
retitle for that okay what is it pay now
love it later yeah that's a great yeah
one of the interesting things about your
work is that is that it has captured the
fascination of not only your boss at
work but but Wall Street Silicon Valley
and professional athletes Yeah right
which is super interesting it's not
dissimilar from I mean Ryan holiday
finds himself in the same position yeah
I think it's it's interesting to think
that those three audiences and I've been
trying to think of like what do they
have in common huh like what is the
commonality between Wall Street's
professional sports and sort of like
Silicon Valley and I think one of the
things that I've come up with is small
differences in how you approach a
problem or make decisions I have huge
outcome yeah variance right so if you're
on Wall Street and you're sort of like
one percent better than other people
it could mean billions of dollars to
your firm on a yearly basis if you're
Silicon Valley it could mean the
difference between you know a million
and one hundred million users and if
you're professional sports it might mean
the difference between winning a Stanley
Cup or you know not qualifying for the
player right when did you first realize
that that your work was connecting with
those communities um you start getting
some interesting emails yeah I mean Wall
Street was sort of the first one in
Silicon Valley was the second and now
professional sports has been the third
and in a sort of major way I think it
just resonates with people who are
looking to get better and
self helpy way or like we're not
prescribing anything we never tell
people what to do we just sort of like
here's a model here's how you can apply
it here's how you can use it and here's
how you can connect it to something else
or here's a passage from a book that
we're gonna contextualize for you and
sort of like connect to another idea
that you've already learned so we've you
Farnam Street is sort of like building
on existing knowledge so the longer you
read it the deeper you sort of like get
in the rabbit hole of what we're doing
and compounding compounding your
knowledge right so we're not talking
about things that change we don't ever
talk about politics or anything
topical it's just sort of like we don't
want to tell you what to think about the
election we want to offer you the tools
about how you could possibly think about
the election if you want to do right in
turn one of the things that you're doing
now is you basically provide coaching
services to individuals - right like
that's part of a small part of what you
do we I do two clients here two clients
yeah right so walk me through like how
you advise I mean without I'm not asking
you to you know tell me anything that's
confidential but you know so-and-so
calls you in and says I love what you're
doing like I need some help come and
come and help me like how do you begin
the process of trying to guide or advise
somebody like that well interestingly
like we only take on I only take on
projects I want now because we only do
two a year so it's pretty easy to say no
to most things and then it's a match
between what is the person one for often
I mean what we've had the last year and
a half is basically I'm just on retainer
and then people will call me when they
have a major life decision and all their
fly-in and we'll talk about it or we'll
talk about it on the phone and a lot of
it is just being an outside view into
their decision making so I don't have
I'm not their friend in that sense I'm
not their coworker I'm their shrink
there's no frame right like I have a
vested interest in sort of like them
seeing the problem for what it might be
more accurately than everybody else in
their life mm-hmm and if you think about
that well when's the last time somebody
came
do you at work it was like here's the
one thing holding you back but I
guarantee you if you're listening to
this at work now and you look to your
left and right those people know what's
holding you back but they've never told
you why because everything's relative to
them so information gets filtered right
information about ourselves our blind
spots get filtered and we can't see it
because we're in the system it's just
like how fast are we moving right now
and you're like we're not moving at all
we're sitting here you know in your
studio in LA and but if we were on the
Sun we're moving at like 19,000 miles an
hour or something around there around
the Sun and if we change our reference
point to the galaxy I mean the galaxy is
also expanding so we our reference point
matters and so often in decisions just
being on the outside and listening to
people walk through their problems you
can find the one or two things that make
a difference to that decision and you
can sort of point that out for them in a
way that other people won't or can't
because they're too close to the person
or the situation and so I mean we've
done cool things like I've advised on
billion-dollar mergers I've done all of
this thing but never from a financial
perspective just from like how are you
thinking about this perspective and are
you comfortable that you've done all of
your work on the decision and walk me
through your thinking and as an outsider
just walking me through your thinking
means you you sort of like have to go
back to basics and then I ask questions
because I'm like that doesn't make sense
and then you you've assumed knowledge
mm-hmm and that's all the knowledge that
you get from being in that system and so
talking about it often I mean we point
out things are I pointed things about
how they can go about thinking and it
perhaps a bit more a different way about
it or pools that they could use to sort
of think about the problem in a
different way but a lot of it is really
just sort of like I'm gonna show you
what this system looks like I'm gonna
give you a mirror or a window into it so
that you can see for yourself and then
you often realize your own gaps like oh
I didn't think about that yeah yeah have
that that outside perspective and also
somebody who can say in your case under
your specific set of circumstances these
are the models that I think are most
relevant to like run this decision
through and then
kind of being a sounding board for that
like volleyball match right right and
then are often it's also timelines right
like in the real world people are under
pressure to make decisions they feel
like they have a short tenure if they're
the CEO if you're the head coach of a
professional sports team or the general
manager you have a short shelf life you
have as a short expected shelf life
uh-huh and so you often will take from
the future to try to improve the present
sometimes you want to do that sometimes
you don't and walking through people
like are you really are you setting
yourself up because that you eventually
have to pay that and you have to pay it
with interests so are you setting
yourself up in the way that you want and
the difference between it sort of like
the CEO and the owner is the owner is
often always thinking long term the CEO
is a very win now mentality and sort of
bridging that gap are you on the same
timeline and making sure that
everybody's on board with this decision
that's right I mean that would be a
scenario in which the the incentives
aren't necessarily aligned like one is
looking towards quarterly earnings and
the other one is thinking about where
they're gonna be ten years from now
right we'll think about Mosher
shareholders their incentive is if we
assume that most shareholders and
corporations want to own the company for
a long period of time their incentive is
mismatched from the CEO which has an
average tenure of like I don't know
three to five years I imagine in the SMB
yeah how do you think about the
difference between failure and success
often luck yeah I don't know I mean I've
had a lot of failure I'll let you know
and I get some success but I think from
a decision-making point of view you're
never the decisions where you know the
outcome or you can't fail are not really
worth thinking about and you have to
determine if failures something you can
handle or not and often we are going to
fail and how do we recover from that is
super important to achieving success
because the odds that you succeed the
first time you try something are pretty
slim if you look at like we're all
walking today and we fell down walking
hundreds if not thousands of times but
we got up and we did it again and so
often life is just getting up one more
time then you fall down but going back
to decision-making again reversible
irreversible like where can you fail
where can you fail and how we think
about what failure means I think we
attach so much meaning to it and there's
so much ego that is infused into into
that we're afraid to look bad we don't
want to you know appear to have fail to
our peers and things like that that
prevent us from perhaps being more open
about taking certain risks the risks
that could you know in the long term
create a you know a better and bigger
growth curve well that goes back to sort
of like how we're living our life like
whose scorecard are we using are we
using an internal scorecard are we using
an external scorecard am i failing to
meet up to somebody's expectations of me
is that something I want to do or do I
want freedom and the freedom in this
case would be freedom from living up to
other people's expectations freedom from
sort of feeling the need to fulfill
society's obligations to me and I'm not
saying like break the law or anything
like that but we're so often driven by
like you're subliminally and otherwise
told that the people who attain power
money and fame are that sort of the
people to emulate like my kids come home
from school and they start talking about
all these celebrities I'm like man I
want you home talking about like a
Richard Fineman Albert Einstein and
these are the heroes right like Elon not
these political sort of people are not
these Hollywood movie stars and that's I
don't I don't want them in that life
where like if they see that as success
because that leads to you how do I get
that success which leads to you I can
step on other people I can do these
things that are mutually exclusive from
living a life that of meaning in order
to try to attain these things and I
think that we know I mean that that's
not the path that we want our kids on
and like who we have as our heroes is
super important right heroes walk
amongst us we just don't do a great job
of shining a light on
best ones and in order to to do that you
have to do a little counter programming
against what mainstream society is
feeding all of us not just young people
but I think some of that comes from just
we were talking about this earlier
reflection right like where do I want to
go in life and that comes from being
alone with your thoughts and working
through your thoughts and having many
false steps and sort of being conscious
about am i working towards those goals
or my not working towards them mm-hmm is
this where I actually want to end up
because so many of us reach our
destination and we're like oh this isn't
what I thought it was this isn't where I
wanted to go and part of the problem is
we didn't check in on the way and maybe
that's a weekly check-in maybe it's I
mean I do it sort of like twice a year
at this point but maybe it's monthly
maybe it's sort of like something you
you booked a holiday with yourself or a
you know a day every every year and you
sort of like go to this isolated area
where you're not around people and maybe
you walk in nature or maybe you sit in a
hot tub or you do whatever you need to
do and you think about am i living the
life that I want to be living what are
the things that I'm doing that are
leading me to where I want to go what
are the things that are getting in the
way of where I want to go and what would
I regret if I died today is there a
relationship that I want to repair is
there somebody that's not serving me
that I need to get rid of because I
don't like their anger those are the
questions that we can sort of walk
through mentally and then we start you
know once you realize it then you put it
into action as you said at the start
action is really hard right you might
have a really close friend who's always
angry and it's affecting you and it's
affecting your health but at the end of
the day you know you need to let them go
because they're not going to get you
where you want to go and you can't help
them
what is that daily practice look like
for you I think a lot like that I mean I
don't do daily I sort of do it um on I
have regular like scheduled appointments
with myself to make sure that I do it
but I'm always thinking about like what
is it that how can I help this person
and at some point you can't help them
and you need to sort of like your
environment will dictate a large part of
where you go in life so who you hang
around how much you care about
people dictates I mean to a large extent
how fulfilled and you know meaningful
your life is so yeah it's just I mean
everybody has their own routine there's
no one prescription for it and there's
no wrong answer to it it's just I think
that if there was a wrong answer it
would be like I'm just not thinking
about it because it's hard right it's
hard to be like I don't want to be where
I'm at it's hard to absolve or hard to
take a responsibility for being in that
spot right and we're all born into a set
of circumstances that we don't control
we don't control sort of our parents
socioeconomic status we don't control
our zip code we don't control how much
they care we don't control the
trajectory were put on but at some point
in life you take control of that
trajectory and maybe it's a teen for
some people maybe it's 25 for other
people but at that point you're in
control so you don't control what point
you're at but you control where you go
from there and you do that through your
habits you do that through your thinking
you do that through your decision-making
and the question that I want everybody
to ask is like where am I going am I
gonna get there is what I'm doing today
gonna get me where I want to go and if
not what do I need to do in order to get
where I want to go mm-hmm in order to do
that you do have to create boundaries
around that solitary time to allow
yourself that level of reflection and it
and and I agree that it doesn't have to
take a certain form like I know you're a
meditator or like I'm a meditator I
could I could do it a little more
consistently than I do all of that and
if somebody's saying that's not for me
I'd still encourage them to try it but
even if you're dismissive of that
finding something that you connect with
that you can consistently repeat with
relative frequency I think is critical
yeah to being able to have confidence
that you're engaging that aspect of your
consciousness but so often like I was on
the airplane yesterday right we get this
alone time away from our partners our
spouse usually the person beside us
doesn't want to talk to us and what do
we do we immediately distract ourselves
right
we can order a drink we we do all of
these things to sort of like I don't
want to be alone with my thoughts I
don't want to think about these things
and that's not to say that you need to
think about them every day because
they're pretty heavy weighty thoughts
but they are something that I think a
lot of people will regret not having
thought of toward the end of their lives
mm-hmm so this New York Times article
came out about you well is that like a
year ago or something nine months ago or
something November 11 2018 I like that
you know the date yeah I appreciate the
honesty on that that had to be I'm sure
that you know resulted in a lot of
attention suddenly coming in your
direction like I've been following your
stuff for a while and you know there's
certain corners of you know the digital
space where you've been a celebrity for
quite some time but that's very
different than you know the white-hot
spotlight of the New York Times it was
definitely an interesting yeah it had to
be kind of surreal right like how did
this happen yeah I was just writing my
little anonymous blog yeah and I mean I
didn't think the story was gonna happen
and I would say I probably wasn't
exactly cooperative with the story for a
long time before and but it ended up not
cooperative why because I thought not
huge on the attentions yeah I mean I did
work for an intelligence agency right I
used to be in the shadows and like this
is as you know big spotlight Ryan
probably yeah it's a it's a different
world right and it's changed a lot of
things I mean for frenum story and not
necessarily for me but I mean it's a lot
of attention yeah
how many people do you have working on
farm Street now we have four full-time
yeah and that includes books the
workshop website all the stuff that we
do and the these retreats that you do
they're limited to a relatively small
number of people right so we teach
decision-making for two days we limit it
to 50 people um last time it sold out in
like 17 minutes and we just do them a
couple times a year
and what is the structure of that like
what is the program that you're taking
somebody through I'm sort to talk about
what does it mean to make just say well
AI mean the whole thing is orchestrated
around the experience right so the
content is part of the experience but
you can't just put people in a room and
expect them to reveal information about
each other or help each other to get
better so it starts sort of like on a
Wednesday night where we we have an open
bar and everybody comes in and so we do
selection to begin with so it's not
selection as in you have to apply to get
in its selection as in the web page is
pretty sparse you can't copy and paste
something go to your boss tickets are
non cancelable non-transferable so if
you're you bought a ticket like you have
a ticket you can't give it to somebody
else nobody's there who doesn't want to
be there nobody's there who's not
familiar with us nobody's there because
somebody told them to go I mean you're
all so when you come to the open bar you
have this social event you have a little
bit of lubricant and if you will - a lot
of people are introverts so it helps
them sort of talk to other people but
you all have something in common and not
only do you read Farnam Street you find
out like you share similar values and
politics we sort of like cover the
spectrum but on a value basis like
people tend to value the same thing and
then the next day you come in for the
first day of the workshop and then that
is oriented around oh how do we get to
know each other better so the first
thing we do is sort of like walk through
I remember that the New York Times had
that 35 questions Duvall in love article
so we did a ripoff of that which is like
I think we did 15 questions but
elevating intimacy and so you so when
you walk in you've already got familiar
faces you sit down at a table with
people and then you go around you find
other people and you start asking these
questions and you're only allowed to go
deeper so whatever number you start out
and then you see the worst vulnerability
well it's sort of like getting you used
to getting to know people on a real
basis right so many times you go to
conferences and you get to know people
but you don't know anything about who
they are what they care about and so
like we're just that's that's all
[ __ ] so like how do we actually get
to know who you are
and it doesn't mean you're gonna be best
friends although we've had tons of
friendships created at these workshops
that span the globe but it does mean
that we're gonna help you get to a
position where you feel comfortable
talking to people about your decisions
and then we sort of walk you through
individual decision making group
decision-making how you respond
physiologically to decisions how you go
about thinking about them and so it's
it's a different experience and sort of
the website and it's very organic so you
can come to the conference like two or
three times so much often we get about
20% repeats and it's just a completely
different experience because you're with
a different table you're with a
different group and the content changes
I would say probably about 25 percent of
the content turns over but most of the
experience is like what am i learning
from other people how am i helping them
how do how are they pointing out my
blind spots to me and how can I use that
information to make better decisions and
all of that leads into you have to trust
the person and so then on Thursday night
we'll do dinner and we do a big group
dinner and again you're sitting with
different people and so we found with
more than 50 people you can't get to
know everybody and 50 is really tough
but like we found with we did 50s a lot
first like two and a half days we did 58
once and it's a different experience so
if 58 people showed up and they clicked
and so what happened is like Wednesday
night you formally click and then you
just hung out with that click yeah and
so when we sell 50 we really get like 48
45 to 48 people show up and then that's
a smaller number that you can sort of
manage you at least get to know
everybody's name sort of and you learn
something about them and you're always
changing seats and sort of so again it's
about the experience and then we we sort
of connect people at the end you can
opt-out of sharing your contact
information and then we just share
everybody's contact information we've
had people change careers we've had like
I said incredible friendships and we
even had one couple start dating as a
result of like these things and I think
it's really neat right like it's a good
environment to but we have all ranges of
society so it's the other benefit is
people who natural
wouldn't talk to each other like when
you think about work or life you're
you're in this rut you're surrounded by
people like you right and ruts probably
the wrong word but you're surrounded by
people who think like you act like you
reinforce what you already do you come
to one of our events and now all the
sudden you're surrounded by people who
have the same values as you they read
the same website as you but they're you
know we're gonna have I think there's
two professional sort of like sports
people at our next conference there's a
couple wall street people there's
bankers there's doctors there's lawyer
like the variety of people that you're
gonna come across is just outside of
your normal scope and we cross all
political socio-economic boundaries
right but all super high achieving
people who have been very successful in
their respective disciplines to be able
to then like for a professional athlete
to say look here's what I do to get that
extra edge and and relay that to a CEO
or you know somebody I mean yeah it's
like invaluable I mean if you're sitting
atop you know a massive decision that
you have to make like should I sell my
company should I get divorced like these
kinds of things like I can see it just
being incredibly valuable yeah and to
people I mean the feedback is really
good from the events we never use sort
of like the attendees from marketing
often it's just a surprise and we sort
of build the community out of that so
it's like now you're part of something
you're part of something bigger than
just showing up to a workshop on
decision making you're part of the firm
Street community of people who want to
improve want to get better help each
other out and that comes with
obligations yeah I'm interested in in
some of the decisions that you made
about how you've constructed the model
for your digital empire right like
you've you've produced a lot of freely
available content but you've also you
know four-walled
some of it and you've developed like a
very you know strong following a lot of
people who care deeply about the work
that you do and it's really essentially
looks like it's moving more and more
towards a subscription model type of
endeavor and I'm interested in how you
think about in a broader sense about the
digital landscape
from a creators point of view because
it's something that obviously I spent a
lot of time thinking about yeah I don't
think I have a lot of rock-solid answers
I mean I can walk through some of my
thinking which is I need to make a
living right so we need sense it has to
be a self-sustaining thing right what's
the best way to do that so there needs
to be some sort of element where there's
an exchange of like were created that
somebody pointed this out to me a number
of years ago and they said you're
creating so much value and you're
capturing so little of it and I was like
isn't that the way it's supposed to be
all right like capturing meaning monitor
monetizing so a little of it and I've
been thinking about that statement ever
since right like so if you capture more
than you create you go bankrupt if you
create more than you capture by why
disparity you can also go bankrupt right
like you're creating a ton of value for
people but if you can't pay the bills
and put the lights on then you won't be
able to do this thing that's creating
all this value for people and so I've
just adopted this model of content will
mostly be free and we will find other
ways to monetize and if we can't
monetize other ways we will charge for
content but content being free means
like our podcast is free but you'll be
able to soon pay to subscribe to the
podcast and get an ad-free version or
get extras to it and so we're not
preventing people from listening to the
content but we are sort of like giving
them a value add where you want the
transcripts you want the add free
version if you value your time it's
probably worth it and if you don't then
if you have the time then by all means
like you there's no no obligation to
sort of subscribe you're not gonna miss
out on that part of it because you know
we're not gonna hold an interview with
like Jim Collins back because you don't
pass money right I don't think that's
right that's right and for me personally
the flip side is we have a community of
people we call it the learning community
a bunch of like-minded people who want
to help each other get better and we
need to add value to them and how do we
add value in a way that is
different from what's freely available
right one of the big feedbacks if you
read the Amazon reviews on our book and
this sort of like struck me because I
was like huh I wonder if people realized
what an incentive they're creating but
one of the big feedbacks is like a lot
of this information is already on the
blog the book is a waste of money like
you don't have to buy it and the
byproduct of that is we've stopped
putting up new models on the blog hmm
right
so we've stopped publishing them because
oh okay well if you know if that's the
biggest piece of feedback we're getting
then we just won't publish them we'll
publish the books and then we'll publish
sort of like and the ones on the blog
are different right the content in the
book is all new it's not the stuff on
the blog it's talking about the same
models but people feel like they and
there's you're going way deeper into
drugs and then I you know there is an
obligation to sort of like I support
people that I value like I want them to
exist in the world I realized running in
business is inherently complicated and
it's okay to pay for content the flip
side of this is like we're not going to
end up with 50 monthly subscription
that's right like you're not gonna
Netflix Disney Plus like that's the
thing right so you and so one of the
things that we did that was really
controversial is we don't do monthly we
might do it for the podcast but we don't
do monthly for the learning community
its yearly
like you give us a year long and there's
no cancellation and refunds again it's
on the website there's no fine print
it's just like but you've built up
enough credibility where you can do that
yeah well I hope so
right and we're always trying to get
better but what I didn't want we did
monthly for a couple of months and what
I realized was like we almost had to
build this system where people get the
receipt and you have to send them a
piece of content like right before they
get their receipt because you get your
receipt and then what instantly triggers
in you is like what if I got fired I
haven't gotten anything for 28 days
right I haven't gotten anything for like
two weeks like why am i paying this
thing and it's like well that promotes
more content more content like I don't
want to be on this content treadmill
where we're constantly feel like we need
to more and more more faster faster it's
an it's it's antithetical to the whole
those of what you're doing right a more
contents on better content yeah right um
more contents often just more content
and you feel like you're getting more as
a reader sometimes but you're not right
well the experience that I have
receiving your email and listening to
the podcast is is refreshing in that
it's clear a lot of thought went into
this and this is timeless evergreen
content and it's been you know it's been
you know proofed and created in a way to
position it in that manner like I know
when I get that email that like a lot of
people thought about this before it got
sent to me and I appreciate that in this
transient world of like content
digestion where everything is a toss
away and I do think it's interesting
that you know you've had incredible
conversations with a wide variety of
people on on the knowledge project and I
think that's another treasure trove of
just unbelievably helpful elucidating
information but in in the way that our
culture digests that there is this sense
nonetheless that like a podcast you did
a year ago well that's that's old news
you know what I mean which is weird
because it's not like totally if you're
looking at a set of encyclopedias like a
and Z have equal footing on that shelf
and they're always sitting there ready
for you you know if they wrote the Z
version of the encyclopedia after the a
it doesn't mean it's any less valuable I
remember a comment on Twitter last week
was like somebody was dismissing
something we wrote in 2013 because they
were like that was written in 2013 as if
like if that was the reason right it's
miss it without any sort of coherent
argument as to why the date of something
timeless would matter so how do you how
do you you know try to maintain the
salience of stuff that you know was
posted a while ago like I'm not saying
you have the answer to that but I think
that that's a that's something that that
I think you know is a challenge that
requires a little bit of thought so
we're not perfect there's some stuff
that we find that you know
we pair but we take the summer every
year June July and August we released no
new content and we spend those months
updating old content mmm so we just sort
of like go through some time we need to
update it if it's evergreen well because
you update the wording right you
updating the connectivity maybe you have
a better write of phrase things and so
we're occasionally we pair things like
we'll remove an article but not very
often
and but we'll make subtle changes to
articles or we'll link it to newer
articles that we've written that might
expand people's worldview of it but
we're taking the time to sort of like oh
maybe that was a little bit more of a
topical reference than we wanted to
write like we mentioned Bitcoin in the
book right but we were conscious about
mentioning Bitcoin because it's like
well that's an ever-evolving
it's an ever-evolving thing and like we
we aim to be evergreen like you should
be able to listen to any episode of the
knowledge project and we never talk
about politics we never talk about
anything sort of like topical of the day
and you wouldn't know if it was released
yesterday or if it was released four
years ago and that's the goal right
because we only want to talk about the
timeless things it seems to me that the
the the heavy lifting in your work is
this inner connectivity piece between
all of these models like I you know I'm
envisioning like a giant white wall
where there's like you know you're
drawing lines in between these ideas or
some kind of insane Venn diagram that
looks like somebody you know some
schizophrenic that went off their meds
is trying to construct like what does
that look like and that is an organic
breathing thing that I would imagine is
very much in gestation and always
changing it's always changing an example
would be sort of like time right so we
have this concept of time what does that
mean well let's think about biology
well biology teaches us that survival is
everything so we need to survive so to
survive you need to adopt compounding
teaches us that most of the gains come
at the end not at the beginning so over
time all the gains come at the end so
you have to delay against at the
beginning you get massive gains at the
end I think you know the story was the
guy who created chess I think I think
it's a legend I don't know if it's true
or not but he asked for he showed the
king the chest and the king was like
what do you want he said well one grain
of rice for the first piece on the board
two for this
and for for the third all the way up to
the 64th and the King the Emperor said
no problem and then realized that was
more rice in the world right so on the
63rd day you have half as much rice all
right a 64th day and so but think of how
does that apply to relationships right
so we know we need to survive and we
know most of the gains come at the end
so when a relationship happens you can
think about there's four permutations of
a relationship there's when when when
lose lose win and lose lose but only one
of those relationships will survive over
time only one of those relationships
will take advantage of compounding so
now we've connected a whole bunch of
different ideas and we've done it in a
way that can direct how we engage with
not only friends and family but
customers suppliers everybody in our
lives right how do we make this
relationship a win for them because we
know if it's not a win for them it's not
going to survive over time if it doesn't
survive over time it can't compound and
if it can't compound we're not going to
get all of the gains at the end right it
sounds like you're aiming towards some
kind of unifying theory of the universe
ultimately that is very like like I'm
here listening to you and I'm like this
is amazing and I'm also like I'm
noticing my resistance also because I'm
like this guy's trying to write a
computer program for you know an
operating system you know and I'm like
I'm a very emotional sensitive person
and I'm I'm like where does where does
intuition you know where does that that
that like I'm a healer where you don't
know where it came from and you're like
I'm channeling something where I don't
even know the you know from whence it
arrives like is there a place for that
kind of spirituality to live in the work
that you do
totally I believe that that's a huge
component into our lives right so I'm
not I don't believe in just pure
rationality I don't think that's the way
we should live lives and I think that
emotion and sort of spirituality and
community and all of those things are
also part of it right we're part of an
ecosystem but individually we have
emotions we need to sort of not deny
them not suppress them right I think so
many problems in society today
from my vantage point is people over
analyzing their feelings trying to
suppress them and not actually feeling
them and delaying the feeling instead of
just being present with the emotions I
think there's a lot of studies that say
if you actually feel the feelings when
you first feel them they sort of last 90
seconds to sort of like three minutes if
you're angry and you don't suppress it
and you don't sort of like analyze it
and you just feel that anger it'll go
away pretty quickly but it's when you
suppress it that it starts to crop up
again and again you become
passive-aggressive and you become
aggressive aggressive and I think that
we need to feel this feeling and there's
decisions that you're gonna make in life
that are not rational and that's okay
right they don't have to be rushed I
think what you want to do is just be
aware that you're you're conscious to
the fact that you're not making a
rational decision or you're you're okay
sort of like throwing the rational side
of your brain out like quitting a great
high-profile job to start a blog is you
know not necessarily the most rational
decision you can make
who you marry who you're in a
relationship with what that connection
is like those are those are not purely
rational decisions those are very
emotionally driven chemistry
physiological response based decisions
and I think that those are equally
powerful if not in some cases more
powerful than rational decision making
yeah I think they can be channeled to
great effect as long as you have a
healthy understanding of that emotional
landscape like when am I feeling a spark
of inspiration or when am i experiencing
some kind of overwhelming emotion that I
that I know is is driving me towards
making a certain type of decision versus
oh I'm just repeating a pattern as a
result of my childhood trauma and you
know I've got a this is gonna take me
down the wrong path even though I feel
strongly about doing this I know well
enough to know that that's not the right
thing to do but so often that becomes an
excuse today too right like we sort of
like oh I was brought up that way and
but going back to what I do this is what
I do right so we we tell ourselves that
narrative
that narrative becomes reality when
another narrative you can replace that
with and often we have to replace
narratives to get sort of better
narratives is that I'm in control of my
life and no matter what's happened to me
it's it might not be my fault that I'm
in this situation but it's my
responsibility how I handle this
situation going forward it's my
responsibility to respond to this
situation in the best way that I can and
I own that and nobody else owns that for
me and I can't blame my past but
everything in my past does get me here
and that's okay that past has put you on
this trajectory it's put you at this
moment in time where you go from here
it's completely up to you though and you
control that and nobody else controls
that but powerfully said all right well
let's end this I think I think a good
way to kind of have people walking away
from this with a sense of empowerment
if somebody's struggling with the
decision like what is the first line of
inquiry if you're sitting in a
conference room and ideas are getting
thrown around or there's some type of
decision table to be made like where do
you begin trying to deconstruct that and
and get people thinking you know right
mind it two things stand out as really
fun to do as an exercise that it's
clarifying so the first thing is have
everybody write down what the decision
they're making is most of the time
people don't even agree on what decision
they're making so they're all in their
super interest to make a decision and
nobody agrees on what that consensus on
what it's like so fascinating right so
the clarity around what your decide on
the home and then are we actually
deciding the right thing like is this
the right problem the two different
things right like do we all agree on
what we're deciding and is that the
right right like level of the problem
yes itself the second thing that I find
really helpful in these meetings is
people often go around and they signal
that they've done the work they've done
the work to be in the room they've read
the briefing they've read the executive
summary they've sort of like done all of
this work and so they end up repeating
the same things over and over again in a
way that signals how much value I'm
adding and that I did the work but
there's not a lot of depth in their
thinking and so one of the ways around
that is just to ask people to
don't say anything about what you've
read or what you know just contribute
what you know about this problem that
nobody else in the room does mmm-hmm
what about asking them once they if they
if they're if somebody's saying I think
we should do this asking them to say
walk me through how you arrived at that
decision or what were the factors that
contributed to you leaning in that
direction right so what are the
variables what are the key variables
that you think govern in this situation
how do those variables play out over
time do we all agree that those are the
relevant variables no okay let's have a
discussion around what are the relevant
variables right and then you can sort of
play out the mapping over time right
like how do those variables interconnect
what assumptions are we making can we do
this in a more often you're just trying
to remove blind spots right or you know
what you want to do and you're trying to
make it more likely that it's gonna
happen which you can come from like what
are the bad outcomes that we can
envision happening here if this project
fails what does it look like if it fails
how do we avoid those as we're going
into it there's a whole bunch of
discussions that you can have around it
one of the reasons nobody's written the
book on decision making is there's no
one way to tackle this right there's
sort of like a way that fits with your
team and your process that's existing
but there are things that you can do
such as surfacing how people think
surfacing what the variables are and not
just getting in this discussion of sort
of like solving different problems yeah
well set my friend thank you thank you
so much
that's what me yeah no that was really
fascinating I think the work that you're
doing is really important it's certainly
making an impact on people and please
keep doing it thank you so I think it's
I think it's much needed in a confused
world and as you say it's sort of your
tagline like you are the signal and the
noise and I celebrate you for that well
thank you so much thanks so for
everybody out there who's listening go
to FS stop blog you can spend hours
going down the rabbit hole there immerse
yourself in the mental models pick up
the great mental models Volume one
general thinking concepts or you sold
out in the hard copies now our copies
are done right now Kindle Kindle and
audio so they're volume two comes out
next month alright well you got a
sign mine since this is now like a prize
you get the og copy she like that was
never that was never the one for sale
you can tell me hover the cover on
Amazon is different from that that's
what I mean so the one on Amazon has a
different cover we've never actually
sold that version of the even more yeah
special event thanks man
all right well come back and talk to me
again man I love that people want to
find you on twitter instagram stuff like
that where's the best place to go Shane
a Parrish on Twitter Burnham Street on
Instagram yeah loves chat yeah thanks
man peace
[Music]
you